on va maintenant faire un peu
d'économies mais on va la faire à la
sauce locale et je pense que ça devrait
vous plaire c'est qu'on va faire de
l'économie physique
je vais essayer de vous montrer comment
de manière simplifiée peut se décrire le
système productif des hommes et on va
parler d'euro très très très tard voilà
la terre vous savez que la terre l écart
et avec un trait bleu en haut et non
voilà la terre alors pourquoi est ce que
je dis voilà la terre la terre c'est
quoi c'est le résultat de 15 milliards
d'années d'évolution
guy vortex hommes depuis le big bang et
donc c'est une planète sur laquelle au
moment où les hommes apparaissent nous
trouvons des tas de trucs pour lesquels
on n'a pas payé un centime et qui existe
quand même on trouve des terres on
trouve un océan on trouve un système
climatique on trouve le patrimoine
génétique de 30 millions donc indice 50
et d'autres disent du reste espèces
vivantes
donc on trouve un certain nombre de
choses pour lesquelles personne dans
cette salle ni avant du reste n'a payé
le moindre centime et qui sont ce qu'on
appelle des ressources naturelles
on trouve aussi les combustibles
fossiles on trouve des minerais
métalliques on trouve des roches
retrouve voilà tous ces trucs là alors
tous ces trucs là je vais faire le petit
ingénieur et je vais les ranger dans
deux catégories distinctes
à gauche vous avez toutes les ressources
pour lesquelles vous avez un flux de
renouvellement extrêmement significatif
à l'échelle du prélèvement humains là
dedans vous avez essentiellement les
produits de la photosynthèse
éventuellement du vent la lumière
solaire en direct etc
et puis à droite vous avez toutes les
ressources naturelles pour lesquels au
début de la partie
c'est à dire au moment où l'homme
apparaît sur terre le stock a été donnée
une fois pour toutes
et il ne se renouvelle pas en cours de
partie ou alors il se renouvelle avec un
flux de renouvellement qui est tellement
faible que c'est même pas la peine d'en
parler dans la partie de droite je vais
mettre les roches les minerais
métalliques les combustibles fossiles
dont le temps caractéristiques de
renouvellement lors de la centaine de
millions d'années
donc on peut dire qu'à l'échelle des
temps historiques ça compte pas un
système climatique qui est ce qu'il est
un océan mondial et ses danses et à
droite
et puis apparaissent les hommes alors le
système productif des hommes
il va toujours être relativement simple
à décrire je prends des ressources et à
l'aide de mon travail et très
accessoirement de mon intelligence soit
c'est plutôt chez les femmes je
transforme ça en autre chose
alors un jour on va se mettre à faire
des trucs essentiels comme des machines
à café des petits gobelets en plastique
là mais avant on a fait des trucs utiles
des pagnes des reproches pourquoi c'est
toujours le même principe
vous prenez des ressources dans
l'environnement voulait transformer et
vous en faites autre chose qui a plus de
valeur à vos yeux
alors au moment où vous commencé cette
activité il n'y a pas beaucoup d'hommes
sur terre et le flux de prélèvement dans
les stocks qui sont potentiellement
renouvelables il va rester inférieure au
potentiel de renouvellement du stock
les premiers chasseurs ils n'ont pas
significativement entamé le stock de
serre ni du reste les premiers
constructeurs de achille sont pas
significativement entamé le stock de
bouts de bois par contre dès que vous
taper dans le stock de ressources non
renouvelables par exemple le stop le
stock de silex à l'époque stocks
baissent alors là aussi le flux de
prélèvement comparé à la taille du stock
il est totalement ridicule dont vous
enquiquiner pas à embaucher une armée de
chercheurs pour savoir de combien ça
baisse mais de fait une baisse
un jour les hommes découvrent l'énergie
et l'énergie c'est comme je le disais
tout à l'heure une manière d'augmenter
votre capacité de prédation sur
l'environnement de prédation au sens bon
ou mauvais du terme prendre ce qui veut
dire que toutes choses égales par
ailleurs quand vous avez de l'énergie
vous augmenter la productivité du
travail et vous augmenter la quantité de
matières de toutes sortes que vous êtes
capable de prendre dans l'environnement
pour les transformer et en faire autre
chose
les hommes ils vont aussi à l'école et
ils découvrent le capital donc ils ont
des bonnes lectures alors le capital
c'est quoi avant même de parler d'euros
c'est une fraction de votre production
passée que vous êtes capable d'allouer à
l'augmentation de la production future
dit autrement c'est des biens qui ne se
détruisent pas quand vous vous en servez
et qui vous servent à augmenter la
production future ' l'immeuble dans
lequel nous sommes
c'est du travail et des ressources passé
dans le passé des gens ont été creusées
dans des carrières faire tourner des
fours à ciment faire tourner des
aciéries etc
ils ont fait cet immeuble et ça permet
d'augmenter la production de recherche
parce que s'il n'y avait pas cet
immeuble vous seriez à -5 degrés dehors
et votre production serait pas très
élevé donc le capital c'est ça c'est des
ressources et du travail passé que vous
mettez au service d'une augmentation de
la production future ça vient pas de
mars
c'est une boucle de rétroaction internes
au système ça vient pas de l'extérieur
alors tout ça est parfait les hommes
croient ses multiples y trouve que le
capital et travail c'est vachement bien
et dont il extrait de plus en plus de
ressources de l'environnement pour en
faire de plus en plus d'autres choses et
puis un jour nos bras d'hommes ils vont
devenir tellement nombreux et tellement
extractif par individu que le flux de
prélèvement qui se fait dans les stocks
qui auparavant se renouvelait fin se
maintenait à niveau parce que le
potentiel de renouvellement a été
supérieure aux flux de prélèvement et
bien ce refus de prélèvement excédé le
potentiel de renouvellement du stock ni
à ce moment les stocks qui normalement
on pourrait se renouveler tout seul se
mettent à baisser aussi deux exemples
parmi d'autres
le stock de forêts en europe a été en
gros divisé par six depuis 2000
le stock de poissons dans l'atlantique
nord a été en gros divisé par dix depuis
en 1910 bien en gros c'est clair que si
vous voulez laisser tranquille
normalement ils se maintiennent à niveau
alors après vous avez une hystérésis qui
fait que même si maintenant vous les
laisser tranquilles c'est pas sûr qu'ils
reviennent aux niveaux antérieurs
parce que de temps en temps vous avez
des phénomènes irréversibles et dans
toute cette activité débridée on va
également engendré ce qu'on appelle de
la pollution alors la pollution en
français ordinaire c'est tout ce qui
nous emmerde
et si on essaye de rester un peu
conforme à l'esprit du lieu c'est toutes
les substances que vous allez introduire
dans l'environnement et qui vont venir
dégradé la qualité des actifs résiduels
c'est ça la pollution c'est des trucs
indésirables des sous produits
indésirables de notre activité qui vont
se disséminer dans l'environnement et
dégradé la qualité des actifs résiduels
voilà ça c'est le système productif
mondiale il n'y a pas d'euro pour le
moment dans cette histoire je prends des
ressources
je les transforme j'ai des boucles de
rétroaction interne notamment la
formation du capital et je fini par
cracher à l'aval des biens et des
services
vos pulls vos lunettes les tables les
chaises les ordinateurs les câbles les
micros la machine à café et tout le
reste
tout ça c'est des ressources transformé
par l'activité humaine et dans la
capacité de transformation des
ressources qui vont de la gauche vers la
droite le travail humain a compté pour 1
et l'énergie mondiale a compté en gros
pour 200 j'y reviendrai après
alors maintenant on peut parler euros
voilà ça c'est ce qui excite vachement
les candidats de tous poils
c'était le fameux pib qu'est ce que
c'est que le pib
ça n'est rien d'autre part construction
que le bulletin de paye de l'humanité
pour passer de la gauche vers la droite
alors c'est un bulletin de paye un peu
enrichi ce que vous avez des rentrent
dedans donc le type qui était assis le
premier sur le gisement de pétrole
on le paye un peu plus cher que les
autres c'est pas parce qu'il a bossé
plus fort plus il y avait la chance
d'être là mais c'est pas lui qui a créé
le pétrole il était juste assis sur le
tape pétrole qui a été formé par 200
millions d'années de tectonique des
plaques de géothermie et l'autre
processus pour lesquels il n'a rien payé
donc le prix où le pib
parce que c'est toujours pareil c'est la
fiche de paye de l'humanité pour prendre
des ressources gratuites et en faire
autre chose quand on a acheté ce gobelet
en plastique un grand coup de crédit du
laboratoire et bien ce qu'on a acheté
c'est tout sauf le plastique tout sauf
le plastique la formation des
hydrocarbures là qui ont permis aux
plastiques d'exister sa mère nature nous
l'a donnée gratuitement est ce que vous
payez c'est le travail humain pour aller
extraire ce truc là il transformer en
plastique
vous ne payez pas plus le faire qui a
permis de faire l'usiné dans laquelle on
a transformé le plastique vous payez
juste le travail humain qui permet de
l'extraire et c'est donc le vous voyez
bien que dans ce système là dans la
mesure où le pib mesure une fiche de
paye pour transformer des ressources
naturelles au plus vite la fiche de paye
augmente au plus vous transportez de
ressources naturelles et comme vous les
piocher dans un stock qui ne se
renouvelle pas ou plus vite vous allez
vers le moment vous aurez des
emmerdements
c'est très exactement ce qu'avait
théorisé meadows
pour ceux qui s'en souviennent il ya 40
ans dans son bouquin fin dans son dans
son oeuvre sur les limites de la
croissance mais on comprend très bien
que tant que le système est articulé
comme ça la fin de l'histoire les pas
très difficile à comprendre c'est
évident qu'une comptabilité orthodoxe
celle que vous faites chez vous si vous
voulez savoir si vos finances vont mieux
ou moins bien aurait plutôt concise
consisté à compter en positif
ce concret à déduire en négatif ce qu'on
a consommé et le jour où la valeur
marginale du dernier de la dernière
table qu'on fabrique est inférieur à la
valeur marginale des dernières
ressources naturelles qu'on a utilisé
pour fabriquer cette table on arrête de
faire des tables et on vit heureux avec
les tables qu'on a déjà
ça c'est ce qu aurait donné une
comptabilité patrimoniale orthodoxe vous
voyez bien que c'est pas du tout comme
ça qu'on raisonne on se dit plus on fait
table et mieux ça va au premier ordre
tant qu'on n'a pas beaucoup de tables
les deux se valent
quand on commence à rentrer dans une
évolution avancées du système ces deux
manières de compte et qui sont
totalement divergentes
encore une fois tant que le stock
initial est infini c'est clair que
deltastock égal zéro première
approximation c'est une très bonne
approximation et du reste les
économistes classiques disent
explicitement enfin certains d'entre eux
dans des écrits il ya deux siècles les
ressources naturelles sont infinis dont
gratuite effectivement delta d'un machin
qui est infini vous n'allez pas vous
emmerdez à mettre des zéro partout comme
le savant cosinus donc le système
comptable mondiale que nous avons bâti
étaient très intelligents à l'époque où
les prélèvements étaient très faibles
il est devenu totalement font
aujourd'hui par un peu totalement faux